اربعه دقائق فقط تفصلنا عن اذان المغرب في
طرابلس هذا الازدحام يتكرر بشكل يومي امام
مئات المقاهي هنا من اجل الحصول على كوبي
قهوه ليكون من اوائل الاطعمه والمشروبات
التي يتناولها الليبيون في الافطار عبد
السلام احد رواد هذا المقهى ياتي يوميا
لشراء القهوه له ولعائلته ليعود بها الى
منزله فهو حريص مثل البقيه هنا على ان
تكون القهوه احد مكونات مائده الافطار فهي
اصبحت جزءا من حياتهم وعاده لا يمكنهم
التخلي عنها
القهوه ضروري قهوه قبل
صلاه المغرب توه طول القهوه
فادي حياه طرابلسيه
انتشار المقاهي هنا في طرابلس الكبرى
وتعدد المقاهي وتعدل واحد يعتبر الشعب
اكثر استهلاك
القش لازم تكون بدون الفطور
صحصح الفطور يعني
اكثر
الى التركيز يعني فهمتني كيف يعني البعض
لم يصبر حتى العوده الى المنزل بل اكتشف
جرعات القهوه فور سماعه الاذان لتكون اول
ما يدخل معدته الفارغه
يتسابق العاملون في المقهى مع الوقت
لتلبيه طلبات زبائنهم من انواع القهوه
التي تتشابه طرق اعدادها بطرابلس مع
الطريقه الايطاليه بحسب البعض من لا
يكتريث الانواع الموجوده هي كريمه
في الكريمه
خلطه بين حليب بطه لا يختلف الليبيون عن
غيرهم في الاقبال على العصائر والحلويات
لتناولها على الافطار ولكن تبقى القهوه هي
الاكثر مبيعا في الساعه الاخيره قبل اذان
المغرب من يرى الاشهب طرابلس العربيه